[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers guten
abend in einen die bergungsarbeiten bei
garmisch partenkirchen haben heute
traurige gewissheit gebracht ein
weiteres todesopfer
das zugunglück hat damit bisher fünf
menschen ihr leben gekostet es gibt
viele verletzte dutzende und es drängt
die frage nach dem warum war es
technisches versagen ein defekt
verschleiß und was hätte das für weitere
folgen klar ist der zug hatte freie
fahrt es gab keinen entgegenkommenden
zug keine weiche es gibt viel zu klären
simon pfanzelt
als es heute kurz nach 13 uhr endlich
gelingt einen der umgekippten waggons
anzuheben finden die einsatzkräfte unter
dem wrack ein weiteres todesopfer
viele helfer sind da schon mehr als 24
stunden vor ort im einsatz funktioniert
man einfach man muss funktionieren
danach setzen wir uns alle zusammen
reden wir mal über das erlebte wir
schauen dass es in jedem gut geht und
dass jede emotional gesamtzusagen die
familien oder nach hause zurückkehrt bei
den toten handelt es sich um vier frauen
und eine männliche person mehrere
menschen wurden am abend noch vermisst
ein stich ins herz so nennt es heute der
bayerische ministerpräsident muss sich
das so vorstellen
das ist kurz vor den ferien im zug
ausgelassene stimmung in einer schönsten
regionen die bayern er hat und dann
passiert sowas und verändert
möglicherweise sein leben komplett
und deswegen ist es immer ein schock
warum ist der zug entgleist warum ist
der mittlere teil umgekippt diese fragen
beschäftigen jetzt die kriminalpolizei
antworten gibt es auch am tag nach dem
unglück noch nicht
bundesverkehrsminister wissing und
bahnchef dutzend nach garmisch gekommen
sie versprechen mit den ermittlern zu
kooperieren
wir unterstützen von bahnseite aus mit
allen kräften natürlich alle
ermittelnden behörden weil wir natürlich
auch ein interesse daran haben dass die
größeren vollständig und schnell
aufgeklärt werden dieses dramatische
ereignis wird umfassend untersucht und
aufgeklärt werden und erst am ende wenn
man weiß was genau die ursache war kann
man schlüsse daraus ziehen klar ist dass
dies restlos aufgeklärt und
aufgearbeitet wird
während die suche nach der ursache läuft
sind die bergungsarbeiten noch nicht
abgeschlossen
die waggons sind mehr als 50 tonnen
schwer zum teil ineinander verkeilt
morgen soll ein spezialkran nach
garmisch geschafft werden bis die wracks
beseitigt sind könnten noch tage
vergehen
die eisenbahn ist das sicherste
verkehrsmittel auf dem boden in
deutschland mit abstand und dennoch
sicherheitsexperten warnen seit längerem
mit ganz konkreten vorschlägen auch die
bahn kann und muss sicherer werden
unser nächstes thema heute abend tag 101
heute im russischen krieg gegen die
ukraine beide seiten melden erfolge
das allein gibt die lage nicht wieder es
sind erbitterte kämpfe konzentriert im
donbass mit vielen toten auch heute
wieder christian kirsch
annäherung an bach mut in der region
donetsk gut 70.000 menschen lebten hier
vor dem krieg jetzt liegt der ort nur
ein paar kilometer hinter der front
gespannte ruhe die ukrainischen
verteidiger erwarten den vormarsch der
russischen infanterie hinter barrikaden
die russin sagte er haben ihre taktik
geändert
sie setzen jetzt auf massives
artilleriefeuer
das klapprig bericht ab einschläge im
unmittelbaren er
diese bilder des russischen
verteidigungsministeriums sollen die
wucht der angriffe zeigen
kampfhubschrauber bereiten den zehen
vormarsch der russen vor die
zerstörungen immens wie hier in slums
hier lebten einmal menschen die
russische armee sei mutlos zu der
ukrainische präsident sie versuchen
nicht nur so viele menschen wie möglich
zu töten sondern auch alle einrichtungen
zu zerstören die wir zum leben brauchen
zerstört wurden offenbar gerade brücken
die ins umkämpfte serie oder
netzgebühren so soll die versorgung
dieser verhindert werden die noch nicht
fliehen konnten
permanente angriffe der russischen
artillerie auch ein deutscher
freiwilliger seeleute getötet worden
sein
russland meldet erfolge mit hochpräzisen
luft boden raketen wurde eine
artillerieschule angegriffen sagt er
dort wurden ukrainische soldaten
ausgebildet an waffen aus dem westen von
ausbildern aus dem ausland
überprüfen lässt sich das nicht die
menschen den bach mut haben lange
ausgeharrt jetzt gedrängt vom militär
verlassen die letzten die stadt
wahrscheinlich erreicht der krieg bald
ihre heimat
was der ukraine krieg und überhaupt die
neue sicherheitslage in europa für die
bundeswehr bedeuten dass kann man anhand
von zahlen sehen 100 milliarden ausgaben
auf pump für die armee in den kommenden
jahren dafür hat der bundestag ja gerade
grünes licht gegeben man kann es auch
bereits am himmel sehen wenn man sehr
früh aufsteht in niedersachsen anselm
stern
wir sind unterwegs mit der luftwaffe an
der ostflanke der nato f 18 kampfjets
und auch eurofighter patroullieren hier
unter anderem überwachen den luftraum
auch an der grenze zum kriegsgebiet
den treibstoff für die mission liefert
vor allem deutschland in der luft mit
dem a400m der jetzt fast täglich
unterwegs ist seit putins angriff auf
die ukraine
man denkt ganz klar über die situation
nach die sich im moment darstellt die
grundsätzlich
beunruhigend ist ein beitrag zur
erhöhung der präsenz die ich sehr
wichtig ist um die reaktionsfähigkeit
und abschreckungsfähigkeit der allianz
zu erhöhen
sagt der kommandant der tag für ihn und
seine kameraden beginnt früh um 5 uhr 30
startet das vorbereiten
nach dem briefing aufs rollfeld gleich
kann es losgehen in wulmstorf
niedersachsen
pünktlich um acht uhr take off
ziel heute ostpolen nach eineinhalb
stunden flug der erste kontakt zwei
deutsche eurofighter brauchen treibstoff
ist beginnt der heikelste teil der
einsätze kerosin wechselt den besitzer
bei tempo 700 und 8000 meter über der
erde
[Musik]
wir haben aus den kameras dabei können
wir den gesamten tankvorgang beobachten
und haben somit die möglichkeit jeden
einzelnen schritt des betankung vorgangs
zu überprüfen die betankung smith der
luftwaffe sind extrem wichtig denn seit
putins blutigen überfall auf die ukraine
hat die nato mehr als 30 flugzeuge an
der ostflanke in der luft und das
permanent tag und nacht
insgesamt sechs kampfjets versorgt die
luftwaffen crew an diesem tag 2 aus
spanien 4 aus deutschland mehr als 80
solcher einsätze gab es schon seit dem
beginn des krieges
denn
für heute geht es zurück nach hause da
wartet sofort der tankwagen einmal voll
machen für den nächsten einsatz an der
ostgrenze der nato
zurück auf dem boden und auch da geht es
uns danken christian seit mittwoch gilt
die sprit steuersenkung die preise an
den zapfsäulen steigen allerdings laut
adac vielerorts bereits wieder an der
ampel koalition mehren sich nun
forderungen die mineralölkonzerne mit
einer sondersteuer zu belegen und so
deren hohe krisengewinner abzuschöpfen
spd-chef klink sprach sich für eine
solche über gewinn steuer aus es könne
nicht sein dass ich die
mineralölkonzerne in der krise die
taschen noch voller machen sagte er auch
die grünen zeigen sich offen für eine
über gewinn steuer die fdp sieht diese
dagegen kritisch
am jahrestag des massakers am pekinger
tiananmen-platz hat die hongkonger
polizei jegliches gedenken in der
sonderverwaltungszone
unterbunden beamte patrouillierten rund
um den hongkonger victoria park wo
früher üblicherweise tausende mit einer
kerzen mahnwache an die opfer erinnerten
heute vor 33 jahren hatte die
chinesische armee die studentenproteste
auf dem tiananmen-platz gewaltsam
niedergeschlagen
zum fußball genauer zur nations league
betraf am abend die deutsche
nationalmannschaft in bologna auf den
amtierenden europameister italien und
musste sich mit einem unentschieden
zufrieden geben die mannschaften
trennten sich 1 zu 1
borussia mönchengladbach bekommt einen
neuen trainer daniel farke hat einen
vertrag bis 2025 unterschrieben er wird
nachfolger von adi hütter von dem sich
der verein vor gut drei wochen getrennt
hatte die polygamie und hat zum zweiten
mal in ihrer karriere die french open
gewonnen die weltranglisten erste
benötigte nur 68 minuten um die us
amerikanerin coco golf zu besiegen und
das souverän
mit 6 zu 1 und 6 zu 3 für die 21-jährige
sonntag war es der 35 sieg in folge
und die queen hat sich heute abend auf
schloss windsor
zurückgezogen denn vor ihrer londoner
stadtresidenz ist es laut sehr laut
dort läuft gerade die platten party at
the palace das große musikspektakel zu
ehren des 70 thronjubiläums von
elizabeth der zweite mit zwei bühnen
unmittelbar vor buckingham palace das
gab es noch nie die jubilarin selbst ist
am fernseher mit dabei heißt es und in
deutschland heute dieser satz die leute
sind gierig nach spaß und freude das
sagte ein polizeisprecher bei rock am
ring und das sagt schon alles gleich
viermal so viele menschen dort wie in
london 90.000 besucher rekord die
festivalsaison sie hat tatsächlich
wieder begonnen ralf rettig mit mir
die sehnsucht nach
livemusik nach festivals nach rock am
ring wie groß ist die vorfreude riesig
kommen drei jahre gewartet
ich glaube jetzt gerade bleibt bis auf
das ist die lebensgroße puppen
die meisten keine auflagen über zwei
jahre legte corona die festival branche
lahm hier ist das vergessen
festival eröffnung mit den toten hosen
als überraschungsgast
90.000 ticket das ist rekord am ring für
die festivals sieht es insgesamt gut aus
zumindest was die ticketverkäufe angeht
ganz ganz viele große und hatte größere
festivals in diesem lande die wirklich
erleben dass
keine einbuße an zuschauern haben der
bundesverband der veranstalter sieht
dennoch große probleme die krone hilfen
haben die fachkräfte in der branche oft
nicht erreicht da sind viele solo
selbstständigen andere oper gemacht in
anderen wirtschaftszweigen sich
gewandelt und das dass wir dazu müsst
ihr uns ganz ganz ganz bitter fielen am
nächsten wochenende findet in mannheim
das maifeld erwischt hat ein liebevoll
organisiert das festival mit independent
music 15.000 zuschauer werden erwartet
wie vor der pandemie zukunft sagen gibt
es trotzdem dinge die über jahre und
jahrzehnte funktioniert haben werden im
nächsten jahr so nicht funktionieren
aufgrund der verknappung der der
dienstleister innen auf dem markt rufen
die hat zum teil das doppelte auf wie
garantieren aber noch mit deals und
kalkulation von vor zwei drei jahren wie
hat es für die branche werden wird ist
noch gar nicht abzusehen trotzdem hat
rock am ring sich ehrgeizige ziele
gesetzt der neue veranstalter matt
schwarz hat schon einiges umgesetzt zum
beispiel bei der nachhaltigkeit gehen
noch fest strom das ist ökostrom vom
nürburgring statt generatoren und sahen
fast das gesamte team ist mit dem zug
angereist gesamte merchandise es
nachhaltig
auch ein anderes problem will matt
schwarz zumindest angehen es gibt bei
rock am ring nur wenige frauen auf der
bühne die italienische hardrock-band
monaten ist eine absolute ausnahme
[Musik]
jeder muss seine stimme erheben um etwas
zu verändern
im ordner skin hatten ihren durchbruch
erst während der pandemie
sie haben viel nachzuholen wie ihre fans
zu den lottozahlen an diesem samstag die
lauten 6 11 23 33 34 42 superzahl 4 alle
angaben wie immer ohne gewähr
und jetzt der blick auf die ziemlich
durchwachsenen wetter aussichten morgen
im nordosten sonnig sonst wechselnd
bewölkt und verbreitet kräftige schauer
und gewitter lokal unwetter durch
starkregen hagel und schwere sturmböen
höchstwerte 20 bis 29 grad in den
nächsten tagen unbeständig mit einer
mischung aus sonne und wolken sowie
einigen schauern und gewittern die aber
nicht mehr so heftig sind 18 bis 27 grad
wenn ich ein schönes fernsehwelt oder so
zwischendurch zumindest dann gehen wir
heute gerne das morgen und wir wünschen
ihnen jetzt noch einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]